I really want to get to my guest Nicole
sedc who is from Colorado but is
currently serving as an international
correspondent for I24 news which is a
station I've actually gone on a number
of times um she has been reporting from
the front lines of the war in the state
of Israel Nicole thank you for coming on
of course thank you for having me
Michael so what have you
seen that's a loaded question um we're
entering the seventh day of the war here
in Israel currently I'm talking to you
from Tel Aviv in central Israel and I
just left my bomb shelter my secure
place within the past five minutes
because Central Israel within the past
five minutes was just under attack a
reported hit in rovot about 12 miles
away from me hit a residential building
there so even here in central Israel uh
residents continue to live in fear
running to their bomb shelter at a
moment's notice but on the ground in
southern Israel about 30 to 40 miles
south of here so still not too far you
have to remember Israel is such a small
country that's where it's really really
we are seeing these horrific incidents
uh reporting on the ground there there's
constantly being fired Rockets from the
Gaza Strip and Hamas you have about 10
seconds to get to a bomb shelter get to
a safe place if you are not near a bomb
shelter or a safe place you have to
quickly stop the car as quick as you can
lay on the ground hope you can get to a
a trench uh and just put your hands
behind your head and and hope that no
shrapnel or no direct hits comes near
you now that's everything that's
happening in the air over head but
what's also happening on the ground uh
seven days later and there's still the
possibility that Hamas terrorists are
still in the area following the initial
infiltration on Saturday we're now
learning more numbers about exactly how
many Hamas terrorists were able to get
into Israel it's more than
2500 now many of them still in the area
the atrocities that they committed I was
in one of the most southern Kutz
communities kafar OA just a few days ago
uh the first day that any journalists
were allowed to enter that area in fact
mere hours before we were allowed to
enter the area there was still ongoing
fighting between Israeli soldiers and
Hamas terrorists but as soon as they
could secure the area as best they could
they wanted us in there to see exactly
what's happening and this is just one of
the many scenes of a massacre Michael I
bodies were still lining these Community
Israeli bodies that the Israeli military
was rushing to cover up as we were
walking through now that doesn't count
the dozens ofas terrorist bodies that
also lie in these former playgrounds
former children's areas I saw a child's
crib that was pulled out through the
front door it was sitting in the the
entrance thrown to its side splattered
in blood a child's toy still
inside unspeakable acts and when you
hear from the Israeli soldiers who were
first to arrive at the scene I spoke to
one of the Deputy commanders who led the
troops in there on Saturday uh to fight
the the Hamas terrorists who had
infiltrated this community and he said
the scenes that he encountered not only
while you're still fighting these these
these terrorists these armed whether
they're armed with guns knives grenades
they're also walking through seeing
mothers children
babies decapitated
mutilated handcuffed and burned
alived it's Unthinkable acts the fact
that I'm hearing this and I'm having to
repeat these acts but the world needs to
know what exactly is happening so a lot
to unpack
and unfortunately it just is all
continuing Michael so there there's been
a lot of discussion over and probably
this is the first war ever where this
has been an issue where where this has
been such a full issue there's been a
lot of discussion over what can we
believe obviously there's always War
propaganda there are always fake reports
and fake pictures and things like that
but just to use the horrific example you
described we saw initial reports that
the Hamas terrorists are killing babies
and beheading them and burning them and
doing all sorts of things then we we
heard that these reports were not
confirmed because there were no pictures
then we saw some pictures of it then we
saw a report that the pictures were fake
the fake the pictures were from
artificial intelligence then we saw a
report that they weren't actually from
artificial intelligence and especially
in an age of mid journey and chat gbt
and uh art artificial images that can be
rendered in 60 seconds how do you as a
journalist and then how do we as the
news Watchers around the world separate
fact from
fiction it's so interesting Michael
because as a journalist it makes it
difficult because you have to trust
eyewitness sources along with these
these images and photos that we are
taking live the there's live coverage I
was reporting from there not not
pre-recorded our station was taking it
all live so that along with the
eyewitness testimony from soldiers and
first responders who were there if I was
reporting anywhere else in the world we
have to remember I'm a journalist I
moved to Israel eight months ago to
cover what's happening on the ground
here in Israel and the Middle East if I
was in Ukraine right now and people were
hearing these atrocities that were
happening to Citizens if if I was in my
home in the United States talking to
American soldiers who were witnessing
and re relaying what they witnessed when
they arrived to the scene of a massacre
along with the footage that confirms
their stories would anyone be debating
this would anyone be doubting this the
answer is no the answer this is only
happening because we're talking to
Israeli soldiers and this is happening
in Israel that's what the debate all
circles around um so as a journalist it
is difficult but all we can do is
continue to tell the facts continue to
speak to our reliable sources and show
the footages and the images and those
live reports I think that's all we can
do is give the
facts what is the uh situation in terms
of your own safety I mean obviously
there's uh just chaos everywhere as you
say 2 200 Hamas militants still running
around wreaking havoc in in the state of
Israel uh
so have journalists been killed yet you
know are you sa want to clarify 2 200
militants not or terrorists not still
running around in Israel that's the
reports of how many were able to
infiltrate on Saturday got now already
IDF has confirmed they found 1,500
terrorist bodies however many were able
to then return back to Gaza versus how
many are still remain in Israel that
remains unknown um so as far as our
safety when I'm reporting down there
driving from live to live hit uh I was
stopped once by the Israeli military
actually we got a flat tire as we were
driving through there um and so as we
were changing the tire as as Rockets
continue to fly overhead the some of
these Israeli soldiers stop next to us
and they say we just want to make sure
you know you're in an active military
zone right now we are currently trying
to secure the area from terrorists we
know they're nearby we're looking for
them are you armed and if you're not
armed you should be with someone who is
armed stay with us if that's the case as
a journalist I don't have a license to
carry it's very difficult to get a
license to carry in Israel yeah so the
fact that the Israeli military is asking
us if if we are armed and telling us
that we should be I think that shows how
how dangerous it is now luckily as
unfortunately we are in day seven and
they are continuing to secure the Border
I think as far as journalist safety it
might be better on that front as far as
no active terrorists running around with
guns knives grenades however you
continue to live with the threat of the
rockets and Rockets that could become
stronger especially if uh the northern
border and Hezbollah and Iranian proxies
continue to get involved in this war as
they continue to threaten to do so
you've got the expansion of the war now
uh obviously Hezbollah from Southern
Lebanon has has come in from the North
of Israel uh Israel has responded uh
Israel then hit the airport in Damascus
in Syria a day ahead of the Iran foreign
Minister's visit there uh you've got the
the former head of Hamas calling for a
day of jihad a global day of jihad
specifically focused on the west on
Friday the 13th not the most auspicious
of days
so uh from your perspective on the
ground How likely is it that this war
expands and how how much will it
expand I think that's what everyone is
waiting to see right now we know that
the initial message that Israel wants to
send is dedicated and targeted towards
the South and they say Hamas will no
longer exist after this in fact as we
talk Israel has urged more than one
million gazin and Palestinians in the
gazen strip to flee the northern part of
the country to evacuate out of Gaza City
because they say in the next 24 hours
we're going to continue to strike and
continue to really increase these
efforts now as the IDF the Israeli
Defense Force is telling these gods in 1
million flee we're coming Hamas is
telling them no stay they're continuing
to contradict that message and that's
because that's the best uh safety net
that they have they're hoping they can
continue to use these human Shields
truly
um and it's it's interesting and now
another aspect that's going to make this
situation so much more difficult is the
hostage situation uh we know now at
least
120 confirmed hostages uh that's
according to this morning from the uh
Israeli defense spokesperson and that
number some speculate it could be dozens
more so we know at least as Hamas is
trying to urge its citizens to stay as
human Shields it has to be assumed that
they're absolutely using Israeli
citizens as human Shields right so the
hostage situation which we still don't
have too much information about I think
that's the most critical aspect of this
as Israel is upping its efforts and
we're going to see a a an invasion from
the ground
on on the potential hostages and on
separating truth from fiction we
initially saw this German tattoo artist
shaie Loki I think I'm probably
mispronouncing that paraded through the
streets by Hamas everyone assumed that
she was dead then we're hearing reports
that no she's actually alive but there's
no confirmation of that either so even
when it comes to the
hostages how confident is the state of
Israel that they know who theost are how
many there are how many have already
been killed and and how can how can we
trying to observe the situation try to
discern that I think that's a a great
question and I wish I had more
information but Israel is being pretty
tight lipped about it understandably
because they don't want to let their
cards loose and so as Israeli citizens
Israeli family members they're trying to
give their best fa Faith to the
government the government says that
they've contacted at least 120 family
members or 120 people who have family in
Israel as far as that hostage situation
the United States also saying that
they're getting involved and they're
trying to work out some sort of
negotiation to free these hostages um
but as far as what you can believe and
what you can't believe I know you can
believe as of this morning there's at
least 120 hostages uh I know you can
believe that Israel is working and doing
everything that they can to try and get
them out and I know that you can believe
Hamas terrorists are likely raping them
likely doing horrific acts to them uh we
know that even filming many of these
atrocious acts that they're committing
so it's truly a horrible situation we
heard from uh there's there's one person
who spoke out about their daughter who
was who was uh who was recently killed
and they found out that she was murdered
rather than taken hostage and he broke
down in relief yeah because he said I'm
so much happier of the two options to
know that she's dead rather than alive
but with Hamas terrorists so right it's
a terrible situation that's happening
and really complicates the war efforts
in terms of retrieving the
hostages are there other nations on the
ground here I mean specifically the
United States we know that there are a
number of American hostages there I have
to imagine the US has some kind of
special forces in their trying to get
them but has there been any word on the
street about about other foreign actors
there's absolutely no word on the street
I mean all we know as of of today is
that the US Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin just held a press conference with
the defense minister yov Galant uh
discussing more of these efforts but
those discussions are behind closed
doors they come out to the press and
they show a united front and you have to
assume that they're working on doing
everything behind closed doors to get
this out as I said keeping their cards
uh uh to themselves because they don't
want any more information to get out but
it's hard for the families especially
and the friends to have faith when they
know little information right seven days
later this is going on longer than I
think many people had expected right uh
Nicole gotta leave it there I'm sure
you're extremely busy uh stay safe we
will be praying for you thank you for
coming on the show and if you want more
of Nicole's coverage go check out I24
news thank you very much boy what a
great clip that was now hey hey hey hey
hey hey ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael N YouTube channel we'll see you
next time